in order to fully understand monitoring
one must have a better understanding of
what quality systems are and what are
their purposes
quality control systems are the
operational techniques and activities
undertaken to verify the requirements
for the quality of trial related
activities
monitoring is a part of the qc activity
monitoring activities are undertaken by
the trial members themselves
audit is an inspection undertaken by
personnel independent of trial in
accordance with the protocol of the
study's standard operating procedures or
sop
it is part of a qa activity
a monitor is an individual employed by a
pharmaceutical or medical device
manufacturer by a contract research
organization
usually acting on a sponsor's behalf or
by an academic
conducting clinical trials some of the
major responsibilities of the monitor
are assuring the protection of the
rights
safety and well-being of human study
subjects
to analyze and evaluate clinical data
to ensure investigator in site
compliance with the study drug protocol
overall clinical objectives fda
regulations
ich guidelines and good clinical
practice
help in the study site selection process
initiate and eventually close out
clinical study sites
to monitor the progress of clinical
study sites participating in a clinical
study
to ensure that protocol is followed and
data is reported accurately
to make certain that the scientific
integrity of the data collected is
protected and verified
and to assure that adverse events are
correctly documented and reported
review all case report forms and compare
them to source documents
auditing is the systematic and
independent examination of trial related
activities and documents to determine
whether the evaluated trial related
activities were conducted and whether
the data was recorded
analyzed and accurately reported
according to the protocol
the most cited clinical trial areas
during audits include
adverse event review and reporting
closure of study or labs
approvals while studying related
activities which are still ongoing
informed consent process and
documentation
drug or device accountability and
protocol adherence
inspection is the act by a regulatory
authority or authorities of conducting
an official review of documents
facilities records and any other
resources that are deemed by the
authorities to be related to the
clinical trial
and that may be located at the site of
the trial at the sponsors
or cros facilities or at other
establishments deemed appropriate by the
regulatory authorities
the inspections consist of site visits
to the organization
and were appropriate selected clinical
investigator sites
the inspection starts with an opening
meeting where the lead inspector usually
outlines the scope and purpose of the
inspection
confirms the inspection plan and
introduces the inspectors upon
completion of the inspection process
if inspectors find issues related to the
clinical trial process
certain measures should be taken here
are a few examples
protocol non-compliance inadequate or
inaccurate records
informed consent issues and adverse
event reporting
some of the major differences between an
audit and inspection are
first in audit inspectors are employed
by the company who work for active
clinical quality assurance function
such as sponsor cro and etc
second an audit is done to ensure that
the site complies with protocol
sop gcp and applicable regulatory
requirement
third in inspection inspectors are
employed by government through the
agency of the regulatory or competent
authority
such as the fda and fourth
an inspection is done to ensure the
trial related obligations
and acceptability of resultant clinical
data is relevant